on est vendredi soir et vous avez une
semaine extrêmement stressante
vous avez eu énormément de travail vos
enfants étaient malades
bref vous n'aspirait qu'à une chose
passer un bon moment avec votre conjoint
et vous détendre vous allez préparer un
bon repas enfin en tout cas vous y avez
mis tout votre coeur et vous servez
votre conjoint il vous dit elle est
bonne cette recette mais elle manque un
peu de peps tu trouves pas et là vous
vous sentez bouillir intérieurement mais
si t'es pas content tu pouvais le faire
toi même
non mais ça va je chéris qu'est ce que
tu as non mais t'es jamais contents et
la situation dégénère
est ce qui vous est déjà arrivé de vous
retrouver dans une situation comme celle
ci où vous reporter sur quelqu'un votre
conjoint ou vos enfants un stress qui
provenait d'ailleurs du travail par
exemple levé la main si c'est le cas est
ce qui vous est déjà arrivé de vous
retrouver mal à l'aise ne sachant pas
trop quoi dire ou quoi faire face à
quelqu'un qui venait de perdre un proche
lever la main si c'est le cas et ce qui
vous est déjà arrivé de vous retrouver
un jour aux prises avec une émotion si
envahissante de la colère de la jalousie
de la tristesse ou du stress que vous
auriez vraiment aimé qu'il existe une
pilule magique qui vous permettent de la
faire disparaître d'un seul coup levé la
main si c'est le cas voilà alors le fait
que vous soyez si nombreux à lever la
main et déjà une indication de l'intérêt
d'inclure un module sur les compétences
émotionnelles à l'école parce que en
fait l'école
ce centre essentiellement sur nos
compétences cognitives sur notre
développement intellectuel un petit peu
sur notre développement physique un
petit peu sur notre développement
artistique mais pas vraiment sur notre
développement socio- émotionnel pourtant
il existe un certain nombre d'arguments
qui montrent la pertinence d'inclure un
module sur les compétences émotionnelles
à l'école
la première chose qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'entre le moment nous nous
levons le matin et le moment où nous
couchons le soir eh bien nous passons 90
% de notre temps d'éveil à ressentir des
émotions et ses émotions elles vont
avoir un impact sur les quatre domaines
les plus importants de notre vie notre
bien-être d'abord penser à comme vous
sentez bien
quand vous êtes serein ou fiers de vous
de vos enfants pensez à comme vous vous
sentez mal quand vous êtes stressé en
colère ou jaloux elles vont avoir aussi
un impact sur notre santé physique il ya
toute une série d'études qui documentent
l'effet du stress chronique ou de la
colère par exemple sur la santé elles
vont influencer notre performance au
travail certaine émotion l'augmentent
comme l' enthousiasme d'autres émotions
comme l'ennui la diminue et finalement
elles vont avoir un impact sur nos
relations avec les autres
la gratitude l'amour sont des émotions
qui rapproche alors que la jalousie ou
la colère encore l'envi éloigne alors
pouvoir traiter ses émotions les
identifier les comprendre les utiliser
des exprimés et les réguler eh bien ce
n'est pas donné à tout le monde et c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'intelligence
émotionnelle où les compétences
émotionnelles identifier tout d'abord
certaines personnes décrypte très
facilement ce qu'elle ressent tout ce
que les autres ressentent alors que
d'autres ont beaucoup plus difficile à
le faire bien évidemment quand on a une
émotion très intense comme ici tout le
monde peut identifier qu'il s'agit de la
colère mais c'est beaucoup plus
difficile lorsque les émotions sont
exprimés à faible intensité ou de
manière extrêmement brève
ce qui est le cas pour la majorité de
nos expressions émotionnelles à l'âge
adulte puisque nous devons gérer nos
émotions et bien évidemment la vie est
beaucoup plus facile quand on peut
identifier ses émotions et celle des
autres très précocement identifiés par
exemple le stress avant qu'il ne se
transforme en burn up ou l'agacement de
quelqu'un avant qu'il ne se transforme
en colère
comprendre ses émotions mais c'est pas
aussi évident qui paraît dans l'exemple
que j'ai donné au début
50% des gens vont confondre le
déclencheur de l'émotion c'est à dire la
petite remarque du conjoint sur le fait
que la recette manqué de peps avec la
cause profonde de l'émotion qui est en
fait tout
l'énervement accumulés pendant la
semaine or comme vous pouvez vous
imaginer
et bien si je pense que mon l'énervement
est due à la remarque de mon conjoint ou
entièrement due eh bien je vais avoir
beaucoup plus de chances de m'énerver
sur lui alors comprendre c'est bien mais
utilisé c'est mieux utiliser ses
émotions ça veut dire utiliser le
message véhiculé par l'émotion pour
implémenter les changements qui main qui
s'impose donc toujours en référence à
l'exemple donné au début
et bien cela voudrait dire ne pas me
limiter à constater que mon irritabilité
grandissante est de plus en plus
fréquentes indique que je suis proche du
burn out
mais voir quels changements je peux
concrètement apporter à ma vie pour
diminuer mon stress et donc limiter la
probabilité de tomber en burn-out
exprimer ses émotions
et bien c'est aussi quelque chose qui
n'est pas évident pour 75% d'entre nous
donc certains n'arrive pas du tout à
exprimer ce qu'ils ressentent alors que
d'autres n'arrivent pas à le faire de
manière socialement acceptable
constructive
or comme le disait déjà aristote pouvoir
exprimer ses émotions à la bonne
personne pour la bonne raison au bon
moment à l'intensité voulues et de la
bonne manière tenait pas facile et ce
n'est pas donné à tout le monde
réguler ses émotions à la hausse ou à la
baisse
et bien c'est pas évident non plus il
suffit que vous regardez autour de vous
et vous remarquerez que tout le monde ne
gère pas aussi efficacement le stress la
tentation ou l'énervement par exemple
donc en fait ce que vous aurez
intuitivement compris c'est que tout le
monde n'a pas de bonnes compétences
émotionnelles et ses compétences
émotionnelles en référence à ce que j'ai
dit précédemment sur les émotions
eh bien elles vont à leur tour influencé
ces quatre domaines très importants de
notre vie
au niveau du de la santé mentale les
personnes qui ont de meilleures
compétences émotionnelles et bien elles
sont plus heureuses et elles sont moins
risque de toute une série de troubles
comme l'anxiété la dépression ou le burn
out par exemple il faut concevoir en
faite le
le rôle des compétences émotionnelles
sur la santé mentale un peu comme la
résistance du bras qui porterait un
plateau si vous avez de bonnes
compétences émotionnelles
je peux mettre beaucoup de vers sur
votre plateau avant que votre résistance
de sède
alors que si vous avez de faibles
compétences émotionnelles il suffira de
quelques verres pour que déjà cela vous
semble trop lourd notez que la
résistance évidemment n'est jamais un
fini si jamais un tonneau sur le plateau
la résistance évidemment de tout le
monde va céder alors nos compétences
émotionnelles elles vont aussi influencé
notre santé physique
nous avons mené une très large étude
avec la plus grosse mutualité belge qui
indique que meilleurs sont vos
compétences émotionnelles moins de
médicaments vous consommez moins souvent
vous allez chez le médecin et moins
souvent vous êtes hospitalisé
en fait chaque pourcent de compétences
émotionnelles en plus réduit de 1%
les dépenses en soins de santé au niveau
de notre vie professionnelle les
compétences monsieur joue aussi un rôle
appuyé à compétence technique égale et
personnes comme meilleures compétences
émotionnelles performent mieux au niveau
de la vie sociale c'est vrai également
meilleurs se vautre sont vos compétences
émotionnelles et plus satisfaisante et
durable seront vos relations avec les
gens qui vous entourent votre conjoint
vos enfants mais aussi vos collègues et
vos amis
alors imaginez maintenant qu'on puisse
améliorer les compétences émotionnelles
que vous puissiez améliorer vos
compétences émotionnelles en 18 heures
seulement
caen 18 heures vous puissiez apprendre à
mieux reconnaître les émotions des
autres à mieux comprendre vos émotions à
mieux les gérer
et bien c'est possible nous avons
développé un programme pour ce faire
alors je vais pas détailler ce programme
ici mais ce programme évidemment comme
vous l'aurez compris il se centrer sur
le développement des seins compétences
émotionnelles que j'ai mentionné avant
et lorsqu'on compare l'efficacité de
cette formation de 18h à des personnes à
une autre formation centrée sur un
contenu tout à fait différent la
profitation théâtrale par exemple ou
lorsque comparé c'était son efficacité à
des personnes sur l'île
d'attentes et bien on voit aussi de
nouveau une amélioration sur les quatre
domaines que j'ai mentionné avant au
niveau pour de la santé mentale on a une
amélioration du bien-être et une
diminution très importante du stress
donc entre moins 20 et moins 40% et
c'est pas juste quelque chose que les
gens rapportent comme ça pour nous faire
plaisir
on a pu attester sa vie à des mesures
notamment de cortisol cas pierre vos
cheveux garde une trace du stress que
vous accumulez et donc je peux comparer
le stress que vous avez accumulé durant
les trois mois qui précèdent la
formation et durant les trois mois qui
suivent la fin de celle ci
on a aussi un effet sur la santé
physique les gens rapportent entre 15 et
30% de moins de toute une série de
petits maux du quotidien les maux de dos
les maux de ventre et cetera alors quand
on prend des populations spécifiques
dont la maladie est influencé par les
émotions c'est le cas des migraines par
exemple 80% des migraines sont
déclenchées par du stress de
l'irritabilité ou de la colère eh bien
on voit que les personnes qui ont suivi
cette formation voient leurs migraines
diminué de 30% les diabétiques aussi
vous savez que la glycémie est aussi
influencée par le niveau de stress est
bien voient leur glycémie diminuer
significativement
on a aussi un effet sur la vie
professionnelle
cette formation vous rend à compétences
techniques et intellectuelles égale
trois fois plus attractif pour un
employeur et finalement comme vous et
attendez on a un effet sur les relations
sociales avec une amélioration de la
qualité des relations avec les proches
et une diminution de plus ou moins 20%
des conflits alors améliorer ses
compétences émotionnelles c'est donc
bénéfique à l'individu mais c'est aussi
bénéfique à la société y compris
financièrement sur ba et données de
l'étude avec la mutuelle que j'ai
mentionnées précédemment
nous avons calculé avec des collègues
économistes que l'inclusion d'un module
de 18 heures de formation aux
compétences émotionnelles à l'école
permettrait une diminution de 10% des
dépenses en soins de santé
donc voilà tout ça ça peut sembler
utopique mais ce n'est pas une utopie
pour autant qu'on puisse qu'on veuille
introduire des heures de cours portant
sur le d
l'opm en ce siècle émotionnel de
l'individu dans le cursus scolaire
le problème c'est qu'à l'heure actuelle
il ya plus ou moins qu'une école sur 100
dans le monde occidental qui le fait et
ce sont essentiellement des écoles à
pédagogie alternative fréquentée par des
élèves favorisés alors si comme moi vous
pensez que ce sont des compétences
essentielles fondamental que tout
individu quelle que soit son origine
sociale devrait pouvoir développer et
bien parlez-en autour de vous parlez-en
aux décideurs par les en politique si
vous en connaissez interpeller les
directeurs d'école les enseignants et
dans l'intervalle
ne négligez pas cette facette du
développement de votre enfant je vous
remercie pour votre attention